before heading to bullhead city  president donald trump did hold a last  minute press conference at the trump  hotel here in las vegas  and he was joined by local endorsers  and i think on tuesday we're going to  over perform and we'll see what happens  at the end of the day hopefully it won't  go longer than that hopefully  the few states remaining that want to  take a lot of time after november 3rd to  count ballots that won't be allowed by  the various courts because as you know  we're in courts on that we just had a  big  victory yesterday in wisconsin you can  catch the  entire press conference here from las  vegas on eight newsnow dot com now